(upbeat music)
Hi everyone.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
developer advocate
on the Google Cloud team,
and today I’m going to show you
how to use Vertex AI
and help a friend get into yoga.
We are building
a yoga pose classification model.
Let's get started.
First thing we need is the data.
For this step, my friend Sarah and I
collected a bunch of images
from our yoga practice
and uploaded them
into the managed data sets.
As you see here,
the images are labeled in five categories.
I can even upload unlabeled images
and label them.
We can analyze our data set
to see that we have
enough examples of each categories.
Now we are ready to train our model.
In here, I’m selecting
AutoML for training method.
You can also train a model
to deploy on the edge or on premise,
or use custom training
if you’re writing your own custom model code.
Now we define our model.
AutoML automatically splits the data
into training, validation, and test,
but we can change it if we want to.
In compute and pricing,
we get to select how many node hours
we want to train the model.
At this point,
we wait for the model to train.
Once it is trained we see it in the Model tab
and can evaluate the model.
We can see our model's average precision.
It ranges from zero to one,
where a higher value
indicates a higher quality model.
We can see that the confusion matrix
helps us understand where our model
is confusing two results.
Now that we have evaluated our model,
it’s time to deploy it to an endpoint.
We can split traffic between two models
deployed on the same endpoint if needed.
Allocate the number of nodes
needed for this endpoint.
Depending on where your users are,
select a region to deploy your endpoint.
And that's it.
Hit deploy and we have an endpoint.
Now we can test our endpoint and the model
by uploading an image.
And yay, it works.
You can also make predictions using the SDK.
If this has piqued your interest in Vertex AI
and you want to learn more,
head over to the documentation
linked on screen.
Thanks for watching.
(upbeat music)